so what are the main economic challenges
facing the new prime minister let's just
go through some of them some of them so
you can control some of them she can't
including starting with this this shows
you wholesale gas prices so Energy
prices and what you can see is just how
much they have ramped up in the last few
years and indeed the last few months
just look up to nearly a record high uh
just recently and it's been bouncing
around what with what's happening in
Russia and Ukraine that is something
that's feeding into all of our bills
obviously and we're starting to see that
now and the concern is if that stays
high it's even higher bills in the next
few months so that's the stars and
that's undoubtedly going to be the big
thing that she has to deal with but it
feeds of course into our pockets this is
one measure of that this shows you our
household disposable income basically
once you've adjusted for inflation for
all the things we have to spend money on
this is how much things are growing so
anything above the line shows it's
growing we're getting better off the
feel good factors Rising anything below
the line well that's bad news we're
shrinking and look at what's happening
in the next few years look red bars
there you can see we're gonna have the
biggest fall in our disposable income on
record so that we've ever seen that's an
enormous thing for Liz trust to have to
deal with as is this next chart it's
showing you kind of a similar thing but
just displaying it in a different way
the higher this line is the higher our
real earnings so you can see they go up
and up and up then you've got the
financial crisis down a bit and starting
to go up just recently but look at
what's happened uh what's going to
happen in the next few years the
forecast for the office of budget
responsibility that's going to go down
quite a lot and you're talking about it
being next year the same level that it
was in 2003 that's two lost Decades of
earnings growth incredibly depressing
there it's not all bad news it's worth
just taking a step back and looking at
some other big statistics and no doubt
let's trust that is going to be shown
all of these things how the UK Compares
with other countries around the world on
unemployment the higher these bars are
the higher the unemployment rate so the
fact that the uks are well middle of the
pack relatively low that's going good
news Okay so unemployment is good it's a
good story at the moment growth GDP
growth ideally you want that bar to be
higher but the UK middle of the pack
certainly not the worst but here's one
you don't want to be high look at that
red bar we're going to show you
inflation look the UK has the highest
inflation rate in the G7 no one quite
knows why but the UK really does have
stubbornly high inflation it's expected
to go even higher in the next few months
and all of this means there's probably
less capacity for Liz trust to deal with
the thing that she really wants to deal
with which is this the tax burden in the
UK forecast to head up to the highest
level that we've seen since the 1940s
she wants to bring that down but what
with everything else she has to do what
with all of these other challenges
there's a big question as to whether
she's going to be able to do that